valerie is with us hi valerie how are
you
hi i'm doing great dave thank you for
taking my call i'm so excited
good to talk to you how can i help um
you have i program and um did you have
trouble understanding you can you speak
directly into your phone please
yes can you hear me now a little bit yes
i am did your program and did your show
and
your whole program about two years ago
and i am an everyday millionaire now
good
um and so yes
um and i had no debt
but um i have now
let my loosened my reins
quite a bit and i've let myself fall
back into
debt and it's the kind of debt
i have um sort of
rationalized to say that it's okay
because it's
debt that's ultimately earning me money
because it's debt on my rental
properties because i own a lot of
residential rental properties
and now i've taken on debt off of those
properties in the form of helocs
to either improve the properties
or i've bought another property on
one of using one of those helocs so
since you're not using our system at all
why are you calling us
well because i was using your system and
i
i i want to use the system for my
debt but because it
helped me before become an everyday
millionaire well what happened valerie
why did you go backwards what happened
well
it's basically because i wanted to grow
i was trying to grow my business my
residential
real estate business and the only
way that i could see to grow it
was to take on some debt and then
use the the rental income
to pay off this debt i got you i
understand not
going as fast and you went back to being
normal so i i
still i'm still back to my point how can
we help you today are you tired of being
normal or you want to go back again
well i am i am tired of
i'm tired of carrying the debt so sell
the rental properties
i i know i should sell a rental property
but i hate to celebrate
valerie we can't help you no we can't
help you yeah
wants to be out of debt but doesn't want
to sell the property
listen you got to do you got to decide
which
ar are you a horse or are you a cow you
got to decide
you can't you can't be both you can't
you can't be there's no house
and there and there is no inbred version
of the two
okay so just decide what you is or what
you isn't
and then you decide what you want to do
i decided what i isn't i had a never
again moment
30 years ago when i went bankrupt and
lost everything and i said i'm not
borrowing money anymore i own a bunch of
rental property right like a lot with a
capital lot of rental property and but i
bought it
slowly and with cash and you have to
decide
what your goals are and i determined
deep in my soul that borrowing money was
not the shortest path
to the kind of wealth that i wanted to
have which had peace
not stress and anxiety attached to it
valerie you have not determined that
and i'm not gonna argue with you no you
can't and and here's the thing dave i
remember
in grad school they would teach us about
leveraging opm
other people's money all of these were
fancy ways valerie to teach you about
debt and what you've done is you've
brought stress and strife into your life
thinking you have a real estate
portfolio what you have is a debt
portfolio
and so what i would do if i were you
when you get tired of losing sleep
and get tired of being stressed out you
call in a real estate elp
you get comps on those rental properties
and you put them on the market
and you pay off those helocs and you get
them out of your life until you save up
some cash
and you buy real estate with cash that's
the only way to do it
or clear enough of them that you clear
one or two well yeah right but let's get
the debt gone kiddo
and you know you you can't call over
here and say
dave we believe in everything you say to
do but i'm not doing any of it
i was it won't work i was waiting on the
conjunction dave no i've learned to
the butt the ore you know all of it
it's coming and it's that right it's the
comma it is and it cancels everything
before the contract
that's right yes yeah everything but
valerie get your life back young lady
get it back you you've bought into this
fictional late night tv real estate
program that's trying to make you rich
quick and what it's going to do is make
you broke fast yeah
yeah you just got to decide yeah you
really do and i you know you know what
we're going to say you knew that when
you called here
and i'm not going to argue with you
about is this an okay thing it's not an
okay thing as far as we're concerned you
knew that
you knew that so you decide what you
want to be kiddo we're right
you're wrong